e
e e
good morning everyone um calling the
meeting to order it is now 9:03 this is
the special committee on Co response
efficacy we are a bipartisan committee
tasked with investigating and evaluating
the state's response to the covid-19
pandemic the committee will function in
a science-based fact finding review
specifically acquiring
comprehensive accurate data and all
related information pertaining theret
areas of particular Focus will include
the administration of federal guidance
acceptance of federal funds and the
implementation of emergency use
authorization vaccination efforts a
report will be issued outlining the
committee's findings and the impact on
New Hampshire represent Penza would you
like to lead us in the pledge please
um there are one two three four five of
us here I believe representative weary
is coming I'm not sure uh I know
representative eel cannot be here there
was a
conflict um if someone could uh send
represent wary a message to ask uh if if
he is on thank you already thank you
represent beler um I actually left my um
phone in the car
so uh but today we're going to be going
over um a report um I guess the easiest
thing to do would be to look at The
Minority Report report first um seen as
that is the shortest of the reports and
uh if anyone would just like to take a
look at that uh representative
Belcher thank you madam chair and I just
wanted to thank the uh Democratic
members of the committee for presenting
their Minority Report and I would say
that I have read it I
see personally no problem with um with
including the Minority Report um except
minus the attachment of the AAR because
that's already a part of the committee's
permanent record and it would make our
report like double the current length
thank you
any other comments uh would everyone
like a few minutes to read
it okay we'll take a couple minutes just
to go over
it
e
e e
has everyone had a chance to review it
and are there any comments represent PO
is
off just asking is it just one page
because
uh uh there is one word on the second
page States covid response and then the
rest was the title and then they had the
after action report attached to it which
I didn't feel like I didn't want to
print out that entire report because
it's also referenced in our documents so
it'll be tach to the final report
anyways right correct and the sentence I
can read you what the sentence said if
we need to do that uh let's just
see do you have that up
Mike represent
vure if not I have it here I'll just get
it done I am pulling up right now it
should be here any second
would you like me to read the last page
here yes please um so I'll start with
the sentence it was on the Democratic
members do not agree with many of the
assertions findings and recommendations
in the report with respect to the
efficacy of the state's covid response
for this reason respectfully the
Democratic members of the committee do
not concur with the Republican committee
members report uh respectfully submitted
signed uh all five uh Democratic members
of the committee uh the date um goes on
on to the attachments from
there thank you represent P
off yeah yeah I can is representative
Bela that I don't see a problem with
including uh this two pages the only
thing I noticed that in the fourth
paragraph there's a little inconsistency
how they call uh the states covid-19
after Action Report like sometimes they
call it
abbreviation ARR and sometimes they call
it uh the report but it's a small thing
uh so overall I I don't have a problem
with including
it like if you go
to the second uh Fifth Line from the
bottom it says uh a
RR but uh
in in the first line of that paragraph
they say they they will call it just a
report I see what you're saying so
basically what they should have done is
after that um thereafter called a
somewhere so that people would be able
to reference that so it should go like
this
correct um right because they put in
parenes the report but it should be uh a
a um and then report also
correct um so it' be a minor uh edit and
I don't it would not alter the
composition of the statement it would
just be an
English uh grammatical
correction
um I also think that I think with the
covid-19 after action
report it says that it was rep prepared
by an independent consultant for the
state um it was prepared but it was
prepared for Homeland Security it was
not
prepared
um and I believe it was at the request
of Homeland Security and I think it's
important to include who requested that
report um that's just my thoughts but
it's probably just splicing hairs at
this
point repres
Penza yeah I wanted to bring that up
piece too
um uh let's see right here which was
prepared by an independent consultant
for the
state I think that's a little um I think
that's a little broad-based only because
um I believe that this was in a sense
mandated by the executive this report
and um whoever was hired was by the
executive and so um I didn't see um all
of the entities uh being put into place
like where was the public component um
there there really wasn't um all of the
people that were affected by this so I
don't really understand how necessarily
independent it was if it was hired by
they were hired by the executive branch
and we're really only looking at um you
know the government entities here so
any other
comments represent po
off no comments for Minority Report but
I will have some comments about coming
majority
report if everyone's okay with the
Minority Report we'll place that aside
and we'll move on to the majority report
okay
please
um I have to thank uh representative uh
beler
and representative
weary
um for uh put pulling this together and
spending numerous
hours um on this report and and putting
you know getting it together um I think
it's important uh for us to go over uh a
little section by section um just so
everyone understands uh where we're at
um also included and um our researcher
Kristen Grant did a great job um on
there's an addendum that I printed out
um single page uh listing um the dates
of all of our meetings who testified and
uh she is now going through to make sure
that all partent documents m mentation
is um uploaded into our website um so
that anything that is referenced here
can be referenced uh pointed to the
website which I think is extremely
important um there is
one um item that wasn't uh posted I
think because the file was too big and I
don't know if representative Bela had a
chance to ex um extrapolate any of it
from RZA um her
information was pretty uh it was a very
large file um but uh if you'd like to
speak to that represent Bela uh I I
apologize I missed the beginning of that
can you ask uh repeat the question uh
yes so we're just going over how
um uh our researcher Christen Grant uh
pulled together all the committee
hearings who testified before each
committee on each date and she's now
going through all the files of
um to upload them into our website so
that we can reference them in the report
um and I was saying that re's file was
pretty enormous um and therefore uh
there isn't anything in there and I
didn't know if you had extrapolated
anything out of that report um that
could be
uploaded uh thank you so there there
were not a lot of direct references in
the report there was paraphrasing and
and various things so I don't think
there was anything that was that would
have been pulled directly from there
requiring a citation of of that nature
but we can certainly add to the report a
um a hyperlink to the permanent record
um
yes thank you um I was suggesting that
we uh go over this uh session by section
by section uh obviously we have an
introduction in the mission uh it's uh
ver verbatim basically from what I just
read this morning
um talked about um how many meetings
we've had how many hours of public
hearings and
documents um and who was on the
committee do anyone have any issues with
that
particular section should probably be
one of the easiest sections to be okay
with seeing none moving
on um so
acknowledgements um
this year we we we took the time because
we realized that we were in a
pandemic
and it was of unknown precedence and we
were trying to make sure uh there were a
lot of people involved trying to keep
everyone safe and we know the first
couple of weeks uh few weeks um you know
who is it for us to you know these
people were working around the clock
trying to do the best for New Hampshire
and we just wanted to recognize uh and
we know that we're doing this after the
fact so it's easy for us to um we need
to be careful because you know we're the
Monday morning uh quarterback right um
but we wanted to thank everyone who came
before our committee who testified we
want to thank all the agencies who
participated and all the people involved
we know that businesses and individuals
sacrificed a lot during this time and um
we need to be cognizant of that and I
think that was where the acknowledgement
came in does anyone have any issues with
that
section summary of findings uh does
anyone have had a chance to look at that
and do they have any issues
okay um represent po off you said you
had something you wanted to say about
the majority report
earlier uh uh I want to thank you for
including uh this uh list with uh list
of people who
testify and thank you our committee
research for compiling that and if uh we
will have enough time to also get the
the list of uh documents that we
submitted or uh links uh and documents
uh um I I would suggest also just
including as a amendment to report uh
the full list of uh uh what documents
was submitted uh to the
committee okay I think uh we have
someone working on that as we
speak we we're
yes it's
okay I'll make sure they don't get you
in trouble or say anything that is not
true to the best of my knowledge
um good morning representative where do
will give you a couple minutes to get
settled here thank you um
sure uh represent pull is
off did you have something uh no okay
represent po off yeah I'm fine with the
acknowledgements so uh you're good with
the acknowledgements okay uh we're now
on uh summary of findings
represent po
off uh I have a question to
representative TS so uh we are including
Minority Report as it is uh but for the
benefit of public uh at the end you
write that you don't agree with our
conclusions so as as we go through
report uh if you could uh clarify to the
public like which specific conclusions
minority do not agree with I think it
would be uh benef icial for people
watching our committee uh to know like
where we have
disagreements um thank you for the uh
request I I apologize I'm not prepared
to do that my understanding was we were
just voting to accept the report um not
to go through it section by section the
committee as a whole all with different
members input into reviewing this and
into drafting the um you know the
minority report so you're not going to
revise the report the report's the
report but I understand you're going
through it for making sure everyone
understands what's
there uh thank you for that uh
representative
Penza um I I appreciate the question
from um um from
representative come on polo polo off
there we go um so but I I wanted to just
follow up with what you said it would be
I think it would be helpful um for all
the time and um and energy that
everybody's put into it especially even
um there's a lot of people in the public
that have been watching this and um in
in listening to testimony and all of
that to give maybe a bullet point from
um the minority side which basically
gives specifics about what you don't
agree with so if that could happen that
would be great it doesn't necessarily uh
have to happen today but that would be
helpful for all the members of the
committee to put together specific
specifically what is not agreed on yeah
I don't know that I can commit to that I
can make sure everyone is aware we we
crafted a a uh a report that enumerated
certain points uh so that's all I can
say would it be helpful for me to read
The Minority Report out loud so everyone
can understand what's in it or do we we
all understand what they have said uh
represent Belcher thank you madam chair
I I don't know that that's it necessary
I think that the report does I mean
obviously a couple issues were
highlighted but I think the report seems
to represent the view of the minority
reasonably well and um I think it's
clear enough uh what what they're trying
to get um across with the report and for
consideration I've added sections to the
larger report to include this already if
we'll talk about that later we can add
it and whatnot thank you okay wonderful
thank you okay um so we are on the
summary of findings everyone was fine
with
acknowledgements um is there anything
you know uh we in here I think it's
important to note that the committee
identified three primary objectives halt
the transmission of the virus and
prevent it be from becoming an emic
mitigate transmission to prevent the
Health Care system and infrastructure
from being overwhelmed and reduce a
long-term term transmission and
mortality rates of the virus through
therapeutic measures um were the three
uh primary objectives that were
identified here um and as The Minority
Report did State
um this was an
overwhelming uh
task uh an enormous task um and I think
we only scratched the surface um to put
it uh bluntly um there are many more
areas that dealt with the pandemic that
we haven't even uh gotten to um and
responses and why they were handled
certain ways um in different
departments um so there is um I think
for the time that we
had we did a uh we did the best that we
could but I think there's still a more
that's needed in my personal opinion
representative
weary uh thank you madam chair I'd like
to just Echo upon what you said because
I think what we're finding out um in
terms of safety and efficacy profiles
for some of the therapeutic areas as
well as the consequences of other um for
lack of a better summary term mandates
um those are having longer term effects
that were just now beginning to more
fully understand so I think the
opportunity
to to Really re-evaluate what was done
um again without playing you know Monday
Morning Quarterback or without uh being
uh you know opportunistic and taking a
hindsight look at things but I
nonetheless I think it's still important
that we we understand the full I think
we fully understand the full impact yet
of what was done and because of that I
think um there is there is further
inquiry that needs to be
performed thank you for that
representative beler thank you madam
chair and and per the um feelings of
certain members of this committee I have
taken the liberty of um typing up just a
brief section for conclusion that might
be added to the end if we decide to and
I'll read that if you don't mind
this committee has spent considerable
time reviewing the events of the past
several years with regards to the
state's response to the pandemic
receiving testimony and documents and
making recommendations for the future to
the benefit of this state however very
much remains to be reviewed assessed and
many more recommendations are likely
that result likely to result as a
consequence because of this the
committee recommends and concludes that
our work is not yet concluded with the
issuance of this report and recommends
that consideration be given that this
committee be reinstated in the new house
session of 2025 to 2026 to continue
toward these ends and to the benefit of
New Hampshire
citizens uh for reference purposes I've
also included a link to our permanent
record at the end of the
conclusion uh does anyone have anything
they like to say about what
representative beler just wrote um
thoughts representative
weary yeah I I would concur I think that
that follows along with the comment I
made earlier I do
think um it it's been very helpful to
this committee to
get um testimony from a number of
different sources I don't think we've
honestly scratched the surface of public
testimony however I mean I I think we've
had the benefit of of of a number of you
know key sort of scientific
Witnesses um especially those from the
state have been very helpful um but I
think I think
um to to be able to obtain much more
public testimony would give I think
government officials a better sense of
the true impact of of what um the
response had on the public so that would
be my
comment anybody
else um I think um I agree I also think
that the mission may need to be amended
just a little bit
um because with um and as our uh steam
colleague represent Merchant spoke about
uh long Co is a real thing that we need
to be looking at and it is the result of
the emergency use authorization and so I
think we also need to be for
forward-looking um in this committee
also not just looking um at what
happened which is extremely important
because it is affecting what's going
going forward um but looking at things
like long cover uh Speech disabilities
uh and the young children that were
masked um where we have now a shortage
of speech
pathologist um and things like that um
so I'm not sure representative beler if
there's a way to um make a statement in
there about kind of amending the mission
just a tad um so that we can be
forward-looking
also thank you m chair I will uh begin
thinking about that and how that might
happen thank you all right back to the
report
uh anyone have any concerns with uh we
let start page
five uh please representative
Penza so if we are to just like make a
couple word changes or something like
that what what is the process can that
be done today and then um and then this
get submitted or can it's right because
they're minor like like on The Minority
Report you know just putting the a so it
references it so that it's consistent
within the paragraph I think those are
minor edits uh would you agree it's
right okay and I would be uh happy to
hear those but yes so so we're going
through we're not going to substantially
change the report but we want this to be
the best that we can do so uh any typos
or editing or things like that I think
this is an important time to do that
okay so what do you
have um please yes so just uh paragraph
on page
five um underneath um so it would be
paragraph one two three it says in some
cases New Hampshire simply follow the
federal guidance I would change that in
some to most cases
apologies what page was that uh page
five
um the first paragraph under the uh
objectives last
sentence where it says in some cases she
would like to change that in most
cases is how does the committee feel
about that
change represent PO is off Sly I can not
find it uh could you help me
um okay is it one of the three
objectives no it's the paragraph
underneath that and it would be in the
last sentence of that next paragraph So
in it says in some cases so it' be
the represent
Belcher I I like the the idea of
changing it I don't know that I like the
specific word most because that's a
that's a quantifiable number more than
not and I don't know 100% that we can
say it but I would like to see a change
perhaps to many cases if that would be
acceptable I I I if we're going to
change it I think many is better than
most because we have no evidence that
most cases but we do understand that
from the people that testified many of
the guidances came down from the federal
uh represent weary then represent Penza
that was certainly true with what our uh
State epidemiologist said and so I think
um in terms of following the guidance so
I think that's that's a good suggestion
which
one many or most many is the preferred
one but I I like the suggestion of
changing it from some to something that
is more indicative of the majority or
you know much more of the federal
guidance being used than just than just
a state guidance
represent Venza yeah I'd be if everybody
wants Ben that's fine the reason why I
say most is because I I follow that so I
I look at just if I look at the press
conferences alone which were probably
more than a hundred um every single time
there was a press conference it was
always referenced whether it was federal
or CDC guidelines every single time so
um based upon every press conference
every single time Lori shonet was
speaking every single time Dr Chan was
speaking it was always referenced to
federal guidelines so that's why I say
that's why I say most we can use many
I'm fine with either okay I I think
um I understand where you're coming from
with the word most but I think many um I
think would be more representative
um it's something that we don't have to
quantify here and represent beler thank
you madam chair I would EO that as well
I I think think honestly the the member
is correct that it is most I just don't
have the number on hand to quantify it
so uh so that will be in some cases will
be changed to in many cases perfect any
other uh comments on page
five if not moving on to page
six e
represent beler perhaps funny that I'm
going to recommend a change having
written much of this but in paragraph
two um it says call was made for two
weeks flatten curve and this directive
led to widespread closures business
closures General prohibition um at this
juncture the previous guidance and
recommendations for mask being worn in
public and social distancing became
mandates I might just add something to
the effective at this juncture the
previous guidance to not wear
masks was
reversed before going in into that
yeah okay go
represent yeah there's a there's kind of
like a sentence Miss in here
because at the time as if we can all
remember at the two weeks to flatten the
curve and all of that piece there was
uh it wasn't at that point you know
there was a lot of conflicting guidance
and really the The Mask you know kind of
you know if you want to call it mandate
stuff was really more taking place later
after that like it started to come in I
would say because March is when
everything happened happened um that was
coming in actually towards the summer
and definitely of course as we can all
recall when kids were going back to
school in um the ones that were open um
kids that were going back to school in
September so if if we can all remember
that so yeah there's a piece here um
because there really wasn't any previous
guidance at that
point represent pull is off yeah I agree
with this change and
I think the previous guidance was like
very telling uh we don't have time to go
on it but uh it was like in my point of
view when when government believed that
masks might help the government told
people don't use masks because allegedly
they were trying to save PPE for doctors
only so they were misinforming public
that but but later when in my point of
VI we already had data that masks don't
stop transmission then they started to
saying use masks because they wanted
like to tell people that pandemic should
be treated seriously so it was more like
social construct so I think this change
will better show the picture of what was
going
on uh represent Bel could you uh read
from uh the call was made for two weeks
just so we
we have continuity and with the change
it yes Madam chair um the call was made
for two weeks of flatten the curve and
this directive led to widespread school
closures business closures General
prohibitions on Gatherings um EG
religious activities Civic meetings Etc
at this juncture the previous guidance
to not utilize masks to medovate the
virus was reversed and soon thereafter
social distancing and masking became
mandates
any
objectives to this okay thank you all
right anything else on page
six I'm just going to State um
on page seven we call the after Action
Report the executive after action report
and over here the co the covid-19 after
action report I think we should be
consistent between the minority and the
majority report and it is called the
covid-19 after action report so that um
so it should be the same throughout if
you don't mind representative beler
thank you
yes I'll revise ours to just say a a to
be consistent with how you referred to
it okay thank you but we can review our
edits
after represent Penza so basically every
time in um so in The Minority Report and
then in the majority report um it should
say the exact title which is the
covid-19 after Action Report the first
time that it's mentioned and then in
parenthesis put AA R and then it can be
referenced to just a a afterwards so
we're all consistent
correct represent beler thank you madam
chair so I've made that change it reads
beginning on page seven the covid-19
after action report a a commissioned by
the executive likewise makes it clear
that the healthcare system was not
overwhelmed thank
you so did make that you changed that
whole line basically so that's
fine any other changes on page seven
uh represent tenza do you have any
changes for page seven any
others okay represent beler thank you
madam chair um with committee's input
I've just made a brief find in replace
change that at all instances of
references the covid-19 are utilizing
all capital letters um if that's
preferred just to keep it consistent
through the document okay thank
you perfect any any other changes on
page
seven okay moving on to page
eight um on page
eight third paragraph down first
line um it just doesn't sound right to
me yes that's a mistake
so help me out
if I may uh please just a okay Quick
Change uh to read instead lastly this
committee has examined and analyzed the
long-term measures taken by the state
with the state goals of reducing the
spread and so on thank you I was a
little confused there for a moment
represent Penza did you have
something okay anybody else on page
eight moving on to page
nine e
any changes to page nine if not we'll
move on to page
10 excuse me representative pulls
off um I don't know if we have time to
expanded but on page nine four
paragraph for example initial safety
criteria are specifically established to
monitor the roll out of these
products so I have a question to
representative
Belia uh if we can
name um what was the official name for
those initial safety
criteria um and that abbreviation
escapes U my my mind but I think it was
those type of statistical analysis that
they initially was suggested to using on
adverse reaction
database uh so uh I would suggest like
specifically naming the official name of
that uh safety criteria that
representative Belcher thank you madam
chair and thank you representative poov
I don't off the top of my head remember
the exact name and I do remember there
there was two different ones and I would
hate to try to get the right one and put
the wrong one in there so if somebody
has the know 100% the correct one
perhaps we could add that but without
knowing exactly what that was I would
hate to add it and then have an
incorrect thing in here
so the question is is does anyone know
what
is uh we can come back to that if you
want to look at up that up uh represent
POS represent beler thank you madam
chair um representative Pensa brought to
my attention there was an error on
paragraph two on page nine where uh
second sentence the word can should be
changed to cannot there was just an
error there
all right perfect um and this is why
we're going through it like this
because
uh it's easy
to uh play Monday Morning Quarterback uh
and catch those mistakes after the fact
thank you
anything else on page
nine
okay page 10
um so in the first sentence on page 10
the word ultimate is pretty strong um I
don't know how everyone I don't think
that that
really we can't really say that I think
that's
problematic but represent
poent I agree I think the word ultimate
can be removed um because it's uh it's
it's too strong and it's it harsh I
think you can take that out and
um you know failure is you know uh I
think keeping that there is fine so
given the failure of our state actions
to have any meaningful demonstrable
impact on the course of the
pandemic um I think that's important
because
to we have to say failure because we
don't we can't say that we there's only
there's two things what that either we
made you know a change or like we
actually there was a positive outcome
which we don't have any any um
information on so it would be I mean
failure is the only piece that I would I
could see in there
um I'm actually representing Belcher
thank you madam chair I think the you
know different words are going to have
various definitions but how they're used
I think the manner in which ultimate was
used in this case was not meant to
express severe but more more Collective
so perhaps the word Collective or um
cumulative might be might be more
appropriate in that place okay um but
I'm also even thinking you know
given uh our state's actions just
leaving that section out to have any
meaningful demonstrable impact on the
course of the pandemic it is recommended
for further study um but you're saying
no um so um because we're still saying
no matter how we state it that the we
are recommending for fur the study
um because of what we have learned
throughout the report and I think
throughout the report I don't think we
have to put ultimate and failure in
there I think the report itself speaks
for itself because we are pointing out
the weak points and where we feel that
they have it was we fell short but
that's just my opinion represent po
off uh when we we have time I would like
to go back to page nine uh I I
found or are we finishing with 10 let's
finish with 10 and then we can go back
to page
nine representative
Penza uh thank you madam chair I agree
with you on that I think you can just
remove both and I think it says enough
if you wanted to um add in a word you
could basically just say given the
collective State actions to have any you
could literally put collective in there
um so it just basically says
all-encompassing so I think either way
it's fine um you know representative
bel's point in regards with all of the
collective efforts so I think that you
could add that word in but I definitely
think you can remove both ultimate and
failure out of there they're not
necessary represent
beler all right took a minute just to re
rework that sentence so let's see how
this sounds instead given that our
state's actions did not have any
meaningful demonstrable impact on the
course of the pandemic
comma comma wh wrong
button it is recommended for further
study and we call upon the private
sectors an Academia to study and at in
the field of mitigation and biological
agents uh anyone's
thoughts represent P off represent wory
okay yeah perfect thank you
representative beler and let's go back
to no seeing no other changes on page 10
represent PLL off page nine you've got
the floor so again uh first paragraph on
page nine uh line five and first
paragraph for example example initial
safety criteria uh and then uh in
parenthesis we we name proportional
reporting ratio P
RR so I think that was uh the standards
the CDC was using uh to evaluate uh
safety signals on
vacines okay so what you're saying is
after the where it says for example then
an initial safety C teror then you want
to put in parentheses what you just
stated is that correct yes proportional
reporting rati p
r uh so technically it's the third you
know right in the middle of the
page uh paragraph starts what is
somewhat concerning
represent Belair thank you mam chair can
you just say that one more time I know
it was prr but does that stand for
proportional aor
ratio proportional reporting
ratio uh
thank you rep pulls
off is that a document that we need to
attach to this
report uh it was in oral
testimony um uh but uh there are some
more
detailed explanation of that
statistical um method online basically
just comparing uh like volumes of
vaccine to their uh reported side
effects so uh I don't think we need to
file new documents it's people can find
it online if they need
it thank you
represent beler thank you madam s so in
response what I've done is I've added
the sentence one such methodology
established prior to the vaccine roll
out was the proportional reporting ratio
prr thank
you everyone everyone represent po
off could you read how it would play
with the next sentence is it before for
example or could you read like all the
changes sure um so it's a middle of the
paragraph on page let's see paragraph
one two three four on page
nine um starting with for
example initial safety criteria
specifically established to monitor the
roll out of these products serious
adverse reactions and Adverse Events are
to be monitored and tracked by the
federal agencies during the weeks to
months of initial vaccine availability
one such methodology established a
vaccine roll out was the proportional
reporting ratio
prr as tracked by these agencies if a
trend or signal of significant adverse
outcomes reaches reaches its established
thresholds for acting then the agencies
typically recall the
product is that acceptable she represent
pulls off okay represent
weary and okay all right any other
anything else on page nine
I think that's going to be the page
we'll keep returning
too if not we'll move on to page
[Music]
11 okay on page on page
11 um are you changing executive to the
covid uh just a a you're taking out the
word executive at the top top of page
11 because it's the after Action Report
the heading corre
anything on page 11 if not page 12
please
for
um I have on page 11
12 fourth
paragraph it said uh the committee did
receive testimony from relevant state
public health authorities that once a
course of action was decided on there
was an overriding decision made that
would uh would not readily change course
it was not a public health authority
that we received that testimony from but
it was someone who was in charge of the
task force and a commissioner uh that is
of um that is not related to Public
Health I was commissioner Caswell
specifically um yes representative
Belcher thank you madam chair I I
believe and correct me if I'm wrong but
I believe that that sentiment was first
received by the committee by um uh was
commissioner Tilly yes okay maybe I I
missed that portion but I remember
specifically uh commissioner Caswell
stated within the task force that he was
in charge of that they stated that you
know they were going to stay the course
and know and they weren't going to make
any changes or Veer off of that their
what they were doing okay uh represent
Penza if you want it because I do
remember um that was at the beginning of
our committee uh that it was um it was
pretty clear that that was the case as
well with um um with Mrs Tilly so but if
you wanted
to maybe you could say um the committee
did receive testimony from relevant
state public health authorities or you
could say or um from relevant
state state authorities because it was
more than one correct I don't want it to
be thank you so if we could change that
and pull out the words Public
Health any other changes needed on page
12 if not let's go to page
e e
oh okay what are you seeing as something
that needs to be corrected represented
Penza
okay could you just point out the
paragraph that we're talking about
represent Belcher yes thank you madam
chair has brought to my attention
paragraph three the opening sentence was
a little bit unclear which perfectly
fair so I've made an adjustment and I'll
read
it IR rationale that authorities threw
everything at the wall to see what would
stick is an inadequate explanation and
such an approach has the potential to
cause inadvertent harm and unintended
consequences okay so instead of saying
suggesting that authorities you change
those word that
wording okay
any comments on that or any problem with
those
changes uh representative
weary um maybe we could just be a
little clearer in in saying
that
uh the authorities were
trying something to the effect of um the
authorities were not sure what measures
would work correct and therefore we're
trying multiple measures
simultaneously uh and then you could use
the through everything at the wall to
see what would stick analogy which I
think is
appropo and then um you know so that's
the statement the the authorities were
trying
because of the
unknown nature of the of
the
virus it it spread
lethality Etc um the authorities were
trying
multiple uh approaches simultaneously
toid at the virus and then you
know I.E they threw everything at the
wall to see what would stick
period this however this rationale for
trying things without adequate
explanation is
insufficient and not having adequate
explanation has the potential to cause
inadvertent harm and unintended
consequences so all right
um so if someone wants to work on the
rewording of that paragraph um that
would be great represent
Penza I think the whole point of it is
um there were what we're trying to say
in that paragraph is that that um there
were a lot of different things that were
used and that were tried because we
didn't know right but in doing so we
have to be very careful to make sure
that we are not um impeding trampling on
the on the rights the constitutional
rights and all and the liberty of you
know citizens and all of that so that's
the point of that paragraph and I don't
believe it was Comm it started off that
way so I think that's what he's working
on right now uh representative beler
thank you madam chair and I would
generally concur I think the the point
the thrust of that paragraph was
intending
to get the get the point across that
when you're talking about measures that
both individually and cumulatively have
real serious um Liberty Financial
economic other implications for the
people of the State uh simply using the
the old phrase well we threw everything
at the wall to see what would stick is
just it just does doesn't cut it that's
not enough of an explanation there needs
to be a reasonable
expectation that there will be first of
all that there's necessity and second of
all that there will be success from from
what is being done um I I'm just going
to throw out there that for me
um when you throw everything at the wall
how do you know what is actually
effective and what is not effective uh
representative beler then represent
poent thank you madam chair and that's a
very good point and just a little later
in the report there is a substantial
sort of scientific breakout as to what
confounding variables are and how you
are unable to determine the efficacy of
any individual me measure when they're
taken cumulatively in such a
fashion go ahead represent Penza yeah
and the good thing about that paragraph
is at the end it basically the last
sentence talks about that so make sure
that we keep that last sentence because
that's that's kind of the most um most
important so right here it says the
people must know that such proposed
measures are temporary temporary with a
definitive timeline for the cessation of
the Extreme Measures um you know you
could expand on that to basically say
Well when a when something's put into
place you evaluate you see if it's
working and if it's not then you pull
that back and then you try something
else that's the most important thing if
if you're trying everything all at once
there's no way for you to know what's
effective and what's not okay
representative
weary so yeah just to Echo that as a as
a process engineer um you know if you if
you if you have um a multivariant
problem with many different factors and
you do experiments to try and either
optimize a process or do anything and
you change them indiscriminately and
randomly and and and are not tracking
what you're
doing you C you cause more problems
because you don't know what you've done
in actuality so um I I think I've I've
made some suggestions to representative
belter uh to improve that and I think
he's uh nearly ready for uh a reread of
that first several sentences are you
ready representative beler indeed I am
here's the whole rework paragraph okay
thank you in response to the unknown
factors being caused by the virus the
authorities tried simultaneously
multiple approaches to mitigating the
virus I.E they threw everything at the
wall to see what would stick however
this rationale to justify a multitude of
measures impinging on citizens rights
and significant economic interests is an
inadequate justification to imp
implementing measures
indiscriminately such an approach has
the potential to cause inadvertent harm
and unintended consequences
when proposed measures also have the
potential to constrain personal Liberty
undermine constitutional rights or
financial freedoms people must be able
to understand the rationale and
justifications for Extreme Measures
dictated by emergency circumstances the
people must also know that such proposed
measures are temporary with a definitive
timeline for the cessation of the
Extreme
Measures any
discussion okay then I'm going to move
on to the last paragraph on that page or
sentence um furthermore given the
testimony received it must be identified
as a fault any insistence something's
missing representative weary uh thank
you madam chair maybe just uh moving it
must be identified as a fault and just
um kind of moving that that concept to
the end of the sentence and then uh I
think it can just be say it ju could
just be said that it is inappropriate or
or something stronger if necessary but
it's it's any insistence on staying a
particular course of action without
ongoing review is inadequate and
inappropriate
exactly okay representative Bel are you
going to read us that sentence now yes I
I made a minor modification let's see if
people are are okay with this
furthermore given the testimony received
it must be identified as a fault the
expressed inent insistence on staying a
particular course of action without
ongoing
review um I think I like the way that
representative weary worded it a little
bit better because it seemed to flow
and there you go representative weary
sorry
e e
representative weary would you like to
read us that yes thank you madam chair
uh so uh further so just the top
sentence in in that last paragraph than
you furthermore given the testimony
receive any insistence on staying a
particular course of action without an
ongoing review is both inadequate and
inappropriate any further discussion on
that sentence okay perfect thank you
page
14 moving
along Madam's here yes I just want to
make clear after before Banning page 14
is only two lines
long okay um I have a something on the
first paragraph one two fourth line at
the end it says it was highlighted to
this Committee in
testimony uh this Committee in testimony
and data that and I would take out very
I would just use
many um I I
think I don't know if you need very in
there that's a personal opinion but I'd
like to see what the committee
thinks uh fourth line down at the very
end uh and data that very
many that many what what section are we
in uh we're on page
14 represent we so it's the uh beginning
of section B so level of disruptions to
individual first paragraph there and
then so it's then um about the
Midway uh down
so so testimony and data that very
many
so is everyone okay with the removal of
the word
very okay thank
you yeah
yeah the next sentence uh starts with
very many so many
parents I would actually take out many I
would just say parents Express to this
committee I take out many I think that's
fine because many implies that we had a
lot of parents testifying and that is
not the case so thank you for
that
e
e e
representative weary yeah uh just
um I'd like to be a little bit more
direct in in uh the second to the last
paragraph in section B there that a
sentence that starts out any reasonable
analysis um I'd like to make that uh
just a little clear by dropping a few
words here so um any reasonable analysis
of the efficacy of the measures taken
must find that cumulative the
measures did not halt the spread of the
disease so or if if you want wish to
make it strong it could be failed to to
Halt the spread of the disease but I
think I think that sentence needs to be
just very you know more direct because I
think
that's that is a main finding of the
committee accordingly and so I think if
we can be clear there that's helpful I
think the word halt without the word
failed in front of it would is is good
because Halt and failed actually mean
the same thing so just use the world
halt in my opinion any anybody have any
discussion represent Bel thank M chair
I'm I'm not entirely clear on what what
change you're asking for if you because
if you remove the word failed it just
reads the measures to Halt the spread of
the
disease uh represent belt uh weary sorry
uh may I
suggest uh the measures did not halt the
spread of the
disease just that did not R would
replace represented a substantial
failure too
exactly we on page 14 are we looking at
so we're on the old page 15 old page 15
oh yeah second second paragraph
down sorry I wasn't there sorry yes so
it would Now read any reasonable
analysis of the efficacy of the measures
taken must find that cumulatively the
measures did not halt the spread of the
disease any other changes on
15 no
okay
16 e
any any changes to
16 okay 17
represent Penza
no representative weie uh on the old
page 17 on the paragraph that starts out
on the other hand okay okay uh I think
the middle sentence has perhaps an
extra word let's see the econ it's the
economic impact should have been
considered excessive long before such
measures were suspended and the course
of government actions changed I think I
think the word was is Superfluous there
I agree
what representative weary and in the
sentence below that um which starts out
accordingly government must be assigned
to you know um to remove the
um in the very
last phrase of the sentence even if some
measure caused by the initial actions
can be justified so just remove of it
sorry to be so word smiy here
I that's why we're here
yeah uh represent Penza
yeah I think one little piece that's
missing here that's
um so the economic impact should have
been considered excessive long before
such measures were
suspended and the course of government
actions
changed I think we're missing something
here um in a sense
where like I know there's questions
above where it's like why you know why
didn't we pivot um we knew data some
data that we knew for a long time
especially if you want to call about the
um with people in the nursing homes and
and keeping um our elderly in isolation
um and we did not pivot and I just feel
as if there needs to be something saying
in there that um why why didn't we pivot
when we when we knew I I don't know
something here that just it's not strong
enough for me in that one paragraph that
I think needs to to
say okay represent po
off uh I I agree with your intention but
I think it would be the previous chapter
when we're talking about disrupture to
individuals uh and representative
weary
uh at at the risk of playing
psychologist which is not my expertise
but is uh my late father 's expertise um
I I think
really
um fear played a large role in in
the reluctance to make changes to
the initial measures being taken I um at
least at some level and I think
that there was a paralysis that occurred
because of that fear and I think what we
especially as representatives of the
people have to look at
is is we we cannot
let fear be the driver in these in our
decision making so um again I I think we
do touch upon that elsewhere in the
report um but I think I think if if
we're mentioning
why this occurred or why things didn't
occur I think that is uh one of the
major factors that that caused people to
to continue on that main course without
or that initial course without
variation I agree with you I mean one of
the things that we discussed at length
and
that uh the majority of the members of
this committee uh had um are agreed upon
uh bipartisanly is fear played an
important factor in the entire pandemic
um and that is something that as we
discussed we're going to be dealing with
for generations to come um The Fear
Factor from this pandemic and um so uh
represent PO is
off so in last paragraph second sentence
planning must be subject to ongoing
review do you want to include something
about fa fair at the end of that
sentence like in the face of Imagine
real time evidence and uh and fear uh
it's uh old page 17 last paragraph uh
second second sentence uh planning must
be
subject to ongoing review and
reevaluation in the
face of fear and emerging real time
evidence would it help if you include
the word fear in that
sentence okay uh represent Belcher thank
you madam chair I I was taking to Heart
the bit of in incompleteness of that
sentence so I've reworked a little bit
I'd like to read it the committee to see
if it's something appropriate which
sentence are we talking about middle of
the paragraph and I just read the whole
paragraph It's not that long starting
with on the other hand on the other hand
if we recognize that the actual
mortality rate was Far lower than
initially estimated and that attempts to
mitigate the spread were failing why
were the measures that caused such an
economic disruption allowed to continue
the economic impact should have been
considered excessive in light of the
clear inefficacy of these measures these
measures ought to have been reconsidered
long before they were suspended and the
course of government actions changed
much earlier accordingly the government
must be assigned a substantial portion
of the blame for Unnecessary economic
disruption During the period under the
review even if some of the measure
caused by initial actions can be
justified uh represent
weary I did you have your hand
no so thoughts on what representative
beler just said perfect uh represent
weary could you could you just read the
last sentence again again please sure uh
accordingly the government must be
assigned a substantial portion of blame
for Unnecessary augment disruption
During the period under review even if
some measure caused by initial actions
can be justified I didn't actually
change that sentence at
all any other
discussion
okay and uh representative P off you
wanted uh on the following paragraph
uh second sentence you wanted uh the
word Fair put in there planning must be
subject to ongoing review in
reevaluation in the face of fear and of
emerging realtime evidence is that what
you were trying to say represent PS off
yes and I want to ask representative
where if it aligns with what he wanted
to say about
Fair per please uh if I may Madam chair
uh may I suggest that we insert a
sentence in there about that fear aspect
is that um so uh it would it would still
remain planning must be subject to
ongoing review and evaluation in the
face of emerging real-time
evidence and and a priority must be made
on uh
providing uh practical solutions that
that assuage or
diminish uh uh ongoing fear by the
public or something along those lines
because I think that's
really
that I I believe one of our speakers
talked about a dual virus the virus of
fear and the virus of the pandemic and I
think it's important
for um for us
to I think I do think we deal with that
elsewhere in the report but I think
think it might be worthwhile introducing
here as represent POF
said represent beler thank you madam
chair if I might take a stab at making a
modification uh with that input reading
uh starting with the word
planning planning must be subject to
ongoing review and re-evaluation in the
face of emerging real-time evidence and
in spite of any fearful rhetoric
occurring represent weary
uh thank you I I think
um it it's more than just the rhetoric
right
um it
it's I mean I mean
there's the I I think officials have a
fear of of if they don't take the right
actions they will be responsible for a
multitude of deaths I think I think we
did touch upon that elsewhere in the
report but I think it's it's
the it's a multitude of of fear factors
not to sound like a TV show but um but
it
is
it's
it's and fear often comes from having un
unknown data about a situ
situation there there is panic because
people don't know what's happening and
they are worried about their survival
and so I think
if
if I'm I'm not quite I'm struggling
because I'm not quite sure how to fix
that but I think it's more than just
rhetoric right so so I'm just going to
I'm going to throw something out because
it was really interesting I went to a
course in
uh in August and they brought up um a
very tragic event that happened and it
was when the uh space shuttle with Chris
moli went up into space and that launch
had been delayed several times and in
the room to make that decision to make
that
launch the engineers were there saying
if you do this this is going to happen
because of the
temperature because something within the
shuttle couldn't withstand the
temperature temperature was too
cold and the executives in the room
weren't listening to those Engineers who
actually
understood and they were fearful that
the executive wasn't going to listen to
them and the EXE the people making those
decisions their bosses were fearful
because another delayed launch how would
that look so they launched and we know
what happened it so you have two
competing um arguments going on right
what is right and what are we afraid of
if we don't act and if we do act what's
the
consequences and so we have to
understand that people have pressure on
them so that is really where their fear
comes in so the executives were afraid
that if they delayed another launch what
how is that going to look the
engineers knew were deathly afraid of
what was going to happen so so you so so
you have competing fears going on there
and I think that you know when I learned
about you know watch this in a in a film
and you know really saw it in action it
really is a good example of competing
fear arguments of
fear but but what happened was and and
this is I think what we found out in the
course of our committee hearings is that
the executive or the people in charge
didn't listen to those in the
trenches and that there is a perfect an
example the tragic event that happened
was because they didn't listen to the
people that understood the mechanics and
were in the
no represent beler thank you madam chair
and with all of that input I'd like to
take another read of a modification to
see if this suits uh the committee
beginning with the word
planning planning must be subject to
ongoing review re-evaluation and
continued justification in the face of
emerging real-time evidence and in spite
of any fear on the part of officials or
the public
representative weary
um So based on Madam chair's earlier
statements there's two there's like at
least two fears going on there's a fear
of public
opinion by mostly by
officials but and then there's a fear of
s of not surviving due to the
circumstances of the
pandemic
[Music]
um are does that sentence capture
that represent p is
off um I I like um the suggestion but I
would change in spite of any
fear uh to not be blinded by by fear uh
because
fear can have some reasonable elements
in it but it's important not to be fully
Carried Away by fear I I actually like
that a lot
uh represent please okay if I may want
take another attempt starting at the
word planning planning must be subject
to ongoing review re-evaluation and
continued justification in the face of
emerging real-time evidence and such
considerations must not be blinded by
any fearfulness on the part of public
officials I'm sorry are the part of
officials or the
public any suggestions of any comments
or is everyone good with that I can see
represent where he's thinking
please thank you madam chair the
um uh could we throw in the word undo
because I want to recognize that that
some of that fear is as representative
poov said is legitimate but there is a
point Beyond which it
exceeds perhaps what is reasonable so if
you could insert undo
at some point perhaps or something like
that if if I may just on that particular
one I'm not sure that's a sentiment we
want to be expressing because it would
suggest that there's a certain point
where fear should be blinding
officials Madam chair can I run to the
restroom real quick uh uh please yes
uh sure um let's recess for 5 minutes uh
we'll come back here at well 8 minutes
10:50
e
e e
the time being 10:50 I will call us back
into uh
session um do we have a rewarded on that
particular line on page
um representative belg Madam chair yes
uh beginning with the word planning
planning must be subject to ongoing
review re-evaluation and continued
justification in the face of emerging
real-time evidence period such
considerations must not be blinded by
fear as especially from government
officials fearful of public opinion
period thank you for that any discussion
on that change no okay uh anything else
on
17 anything none let's go to
18 thank you
represent Belcher thank you madam chair
just a minor change I would recommend is
uh in the parenthesis in the first
paragraph says which probably caused
harm I think we can reasonably remove
the word probably I think it's been
demonstrated that there was harm
expressed by such parents um I don't
think we have to quantify a specific
amount to to get rid of that
okay I have no objections to that
anybody else
okay thank you for that
change anything else on page
18 page
19 anything
is everyone okay with page
19 and Page 20 is really
easy okay okay page 21 uh is a new topic
so if anyone has any take a
minute in on page 21 represent belter I
would take out the word very in the
first sentence
represent P
off uh can we go back to page
19 the paragraph on the bottom that
starts with
significant and second
sentence the spread of long established
pathogens such as the cold and flu virus
I wonder if the word virus should be
plural
here like the cult and flu viruses or
should we just take out the word flu and
just leave virus
viruses okay thank
you thank you for that represent PS off
okay e
representative Belair thank you madam
chair I think it's probably going to be
on page maybe the beginning of page 22
for you because I'm still working on the
edited document um
um paragraph starts with as mentioned
previously
comma that's at the bottom of page 21
okay uh down where it says it's like
near the end of it it says um the state
executive branch to direct their own
branch of government through their own
uh constitutionally draw executive
Authority um I
think the word Branch after executive is
actually um unnecessary and confusing
using in this context um because it's
referring to the
executive I would agree with
you thank
you so do you think branch in the
sentence is okay though uh for that I'm
just going to question
you I
do any other changes on
21 represent weary
uh do we need uh again pick on word
smithing a federal hyphen appointed and
state hyphen appointed
where are you uh first sentence on the
last paragraph As mentioned previously
the existence of a chain of command
between the federal hyphen appointed
executive branch and the state hyphen
appointed executive
branch if I may represent Bel I I don't
think that would be quite right because
that would have that would lend the
suggestion that it's the same executive
branch we're talking about as opposed to
two different branches
if I may elaborate just it if you were
to hyphenate it it sounds it sounds like
there's a certain part of there there
there's some executive branch that some
members are appointed by the state some
are by the federal but it's actually two
separate executive
branches if I may then uh could we could
we just
say between the Federal Executive Branch
and the state executive
branch if I may uh I the only reason I
would caution against that is because
it's important to point out that we're
talking about the appointed members and
not the elected members here because it
wouldn't it wouldn't ostensively a
represented constitutional issue for the
executive of the federal government to
make a recommendation to the executive
of the state government and for that
executive to then decide to do that but
coming directly from appointed officials
of the Federal Branch to appointed
officials of the State Branch it cuts
out those elected members and that's I
think the point we're really trying to
make please yeah if I thank you madam
chair then I think we need
to clarify that that when we say
executive branch we need the
administrative
personnel and it's
not it's appointed officials not elected
officials I don't think you can do that
because some of the people on in in
making those decisions were
elected because you had actually a task
force of elected officials and
administrative officials so you have to
be very careful in how you were
that because it was both
making the
decisions so I'm open for suggestions as
long as it it will include
[Music]
both represent beler thank you madam
chair I think I can rework this to the
satisfaction to the point that's trying
to be made but to your point I the this
stands alone this issue stands alone as
a as a separate issue from that
committee that that that you spoke of
this is this is the existence in law of
a direct uh order hierarchy between uh
appointed members of the Federal
Executive directly to appointed members
of the state executive that authorizes
them to take action without the input of
the elected members of the state
executive which is is the issue that's
being brought up well I guess I would
have to point out that the governor is
elected
yes that that is correct but within law
this is something that came up during
DHS testimonies that there is a
provision in law a statute that
authorizes the state appointed members
of the executive to take Direction
directly from appointed members of the
Federal Executive so DHS directly to DHS
without necessarily having the input of
the governor or other or the EXE um
counsil for that matter so it in theory
and I'm not saying it necessarily did
all the time but in theory it authorizes
them to cut out those elected members
thank you for that
explanation um so uh you said you had a
change that you thought would be
acceptable to everyone that'd be great
represent POS
off uh I think
uh I would suggest not changing this
paragraph uh I don't know how other
members
feel represent beler thank you i' I've
made a stylistic change just I think
make it more clear um if if I may
beginning with the as mentioned
previously the existence of a chain of
command between appointed members of the
Federal Executive Branch directly to
appointed members of the state executive
branch comes with significant
constitutional
concerns I like that change I do too
because you just changed the word
appointed is really and I think that
makes it uh much clearer so thank you uh
represent PS off any objection okay
thank you
anything on
22 if not we'll move to 23
uh yes that would be two
hes thank you for that catch
e e
okay so on the bottom of page 23
um it's a runon it's a runon sentence
we've got to either break that up or
whatever so because it it it's got a lot
in there it's just too much um so it
starts off in the future decisions while
properly considering expert opinion on
matters you know make a statement and
then we should finish it off that should
be two
sentences what's
everybody's uh I had a weird edit there
hold on one sec uh just to modify that
if this is appropriate in the future
decisions while properly considering
expert opinions on matters ought to be
the purview of only elected and
accountable officials these officials
ought to always weigh counterveiling
considerations to emergency actions to
and avoid the pitfalls of safetyism and
crafting
policy um I have a question on this
section because we're talking about
um critical
capacity the roll out Etc is there
anything in here after this section that
talks about how nursing
homes um were affected by the federal
mandates of the
dollars um that resulted in loss of um
nursing staff um I think it's important
somewhere I don't know if it's in here
so that's why I'm asking because as was
discussed in at our county level um that
we discussed um Public Health as a
priority with um our
colleagues on on the other side that we
need to be making sure that um you know
we we have
Staffing
at hospitals and nursing homes Etc but
we also know that we lost a tremendous
amount of Staffing due to the
mandates from the federal government not
the state
government because if you received the I
believe it's the Medicaid
dollars you had to make sure you
complied with Federal and therefore uh
that impacted our elderly in a in a way
that uh we can't even
explain um so I'm just asking I know
that if it's not included I understand
but I just wanted to because we're
talking about how um good things were
but I think that is an area that was
really important represent Belgium thank
you madam chair I I do not believe it
was covered in that level of specificity
but I think what we will find is that
there is discussion of in a more General
sense the effect of um particularly
Federal guidance on on the Health Care
system thank you for that
uh any other changes on
23 if not let's move
on
e e
anything on 20 24 or
nope go on to
masking e
on page 26 second paragraph
um starts off efficacy propo
professional fitted should it be
professionally fitted
n95 type mask I'm just huh question
because it is my understanding that if
you are doing have an n95 mask it must
be professionally fitted and I don't
think there needs to be a comma there
it's it's professionally fitted n95
mask does anyone have any comments on
that change represent weary uh you you
can obtain masks that are in 95 I
believe you can obtain mass that are in
95 without having them professionally
fitted representative Bel that is
correct like I can buy my own 95 Mass
but this specific sentence is
referencing a study that was submitted
to this Committee in which there were
Professional healthc Care Professionals
utilizing fitted in 95 type masks under
control conditions in hospitals so
that's that's the
context so my question is is
professionally fitted
uh what it should be or should it be
left alone uh representative weary could
could we just change the word
in so the only piece of evidence
provided to this commit is support of
masking efficacy was a single study that
found possible
efficacy when purposed professional
fitted n95 type masks were used in
controlled conditions so just to clarify
that because I think it's worth pointing
out the
study um and the
limited data available on this but but
to be to your to the earlier points that
were raised um
clarifying uh the type of mask and the
conditions that the mask was were used
in for those
conditions could you just read that
change to us please sure here uh
beginning with the only the only piece
of EV evidence provided to this
Committee in support of masking efficacy
was a single study that found possible
efficacy when purposed professionally
fitted n95 type masks were utilized
under controlled
conditions thank you
representative
wey um in reviewing this um for um again
um there's one aspect that I'm not sure
we've addressed here that I think is
worth while I'm not sure if it's too
late but um
there actually is an adverse reaction
from ongoing wearing of masks from you
know uh like homemade masks where the
The Masks become saturated
with
um
uh bacteria and it it also has an
ongoing effect of limiting the amount of
oxygen that PE the wearers can draw in
so I think there are
actually
um May maybe there's a way when we talk
about homemade masks uh and maybe that
was the paragraph that that caught my
eye that made me think of this is that
um the
um adverse effects from the ongoing
where ing of homemade
Mass um did not
or the ongoing wearing of homemade
Mass did not account
for uh proper proper cleaning of the
masks um possible contamination by
bacteria of the masks and a
possible
um lessening of oxygen intake something
along those lines because I think those
are uh genuine issues that that still
persist quite frankly okay although I
agree with you represent weary uh we
didn't have uh data submitted to us
regarding that um I know there was some
discussion about um people getting
sicker from wearing masks um and maybe
that's one of the subjects in an ongoing
committee that we delve into further but
representative Belch than representative
penzo thank you madam chair I I don't
disagree um with representative wry
about the it might be nice to have that
but I do think it this point it's too
late to get into it only because not not
because it would be too difficult just
to enter that sentence or paragraph but
then to justify it a based on the
evidentiary basis that we have on the
record in this committee and then some
of the complicating factors are such as
it's a very good point that it could be
um a problem for people who are you know
compromis in some way but then we would
have to go look at okay well the
governor's order actually did exempt
people who were immuno compromis so does
that conflict with the statement we're
making at this point it it's just I
think it's a lot to try to handle at
this very last
minute repres represent
Penza if we want to
have studies put in for the record um
there was so the gentleman that came and
testified and spent a long time here um
um the expert on masks uh um Mr Petty we
can we can add that stuff in there's
there's many many things that he
referenced in his um in his presentation
that are um that were links or or um um
what do you want to call it studies that
were that have been done I have all of
that information so um if you'd like I
mean we could you know if I don't think
we should change this but we could
literally add a line if you wanted to to
reference that and I will upload them
all for um that are underneath all of
the masking session which pretty much Mr
Petty touched on almost every single one
of them so it would be it's going to be
based upon studies that have taken place
a long time ago all the way up until
recent ones over the last two to three
years
um we do have his testimony and his
PowerPoint presentation attached to our
website uh so um represent Belair
representative weary thank you madam
chair and I I I don't disagree with the
fact that we have that testimony in the
record I think the continued
complication is going to be depending on
exactly what we were trying to input we
would still need to go back to the
actual emergency order regarding face
coverings and the extra ordinarily long
list of exemptions that existed in order
to justify what we're putting in this cu
the trouble is clearly the private
sector didn't realize this list of
exemptions and all these people were
nonetheless forced in many cases to wear
masks even though they were technically
Exempted under the order and so we have
to deal with are we dealing with the
executive order which did exempt them or
the way that they were inforced um which
which creates a complication as far as
if we're going to criticize government
policy technically it may not have been
government
policy represent
weary um thank you mam chair so in the
paragraph in the third paragraph under
the masking uh in the section we do talk
about Exempted persons and we I think we
we so I think that's addressed my
suggestion would be to along with what
representative Potenza mentioned is
simply saying in the paragraph that
starts out the Mandate from asking
quickly devolved um we could we could
say maybe have a add an additional
sentence that says you know uh one
expert heard by the committee testified
about issues associated
with um the wearing a mask and and this
uh would bear further study
um which bear or which Bears further
study
I would be acceptable with that
statement yeah I'm okay with that
represent
beler I have an edit I can read to see
if this is satisfactory um I'll start
with the reality is this these face
coverings often consist of an old cost
cotton t-shirt or the equivalent expert
testimony was received by this committee
to the effect of maske wearing of this
sort contributing toward negative
effects including contaminating by
bacteria and increased work of
breathing any comments
suggestions represented weary would
would the final sentence still be there
the this committee was presented okay
okay anybody else no good okay um moving
on to page 27 we have uh we are getting
down to limited time we have you know so
I just want to throw that out there for
everyone
represent beler thank you just minor
change uh I'm not sure page is 20
probably 27 okay um this Mass mandate
greatly infringed on the rights of
citizens and created a Divi of a
divisive false Paradigm I don't think
the word uh false is necessary there
just a divisive paradigm I think that's
a good idea so thank you for
that any other suggestions on
27 yeah I'm I'm not gonna um I'm not
gonna we're not going to make this
change now I just I really wish there
was a paragraph that just like
specifically talked about about schools
and uh I don't feel as if that's covered
enough but
um I think you miss the part on
education oh that's we went over that
earlier that's right I was missing that
sorry any other changes uh otherwise
e
e e
any suggestions on 28 or 29 I think
that's where we're at
representative weary is it too
overreaching to say um sorry page 29
middle paragraph starts out the specific
emergency orders in
question and then what I what I
would I I was thinking that
these the exercise of these Powers
bordered on like martial law
and I was wondering if we
could um maybe in that middle sentence
State something to that effect as such
the exercise of these Powers was
entirely a state prerogative and
bordered on martial law is that too
strong or is that incorrect I I just
think representative Penza then
representative
beler I agree with
um I agree with adding something I don't
know if we want that except for I think
we should I think we should prefer the
specific emergency orders there were
literally um over a hundred executive
and emergency orders that took place uh
completely overreach by one branch when
we're supposed to have three branches of
government that are all checks and
balances so if we can talk about if we
can say
severe unconstitutional overreach I
would rather that than in regards with
you know in saying martial
law representative Belcher thank you
madam chair I I would tend to agree that
I think so when I view the idea of
Martial law I think that that's actually
a very specific thing it's not a general
thing and I don't think it qualifies
what happened but I do think maybe the
term extra
constitutional might be appropriate in
that context because it it exceeds ceeds
what is constitutionally available as
Powers representative
Penza for
example uh a very good friend of mine
was was arrested for not wearing a mask
when she literally has a a
medical exemption from wearing a mask
and it didn't matter and the police
still arrested her you know quote
unquote following orders and so I really
do believe that and that happened in
many places over the state um maybe not
as much as in other states but I think
those types of things um have to be
brought up here um in in in a in a
general sense and so that's why I would
really like it to say you know in
regards with severe constitutional
issues um and
overreach and uh an unbelievable amount
of of emergency and executive orders
okay representative Belcher Madam chair
if I may take a shot at trying this
amendment please the ending of the first
paragraph in section
c these measures were documented as
being significantly disruptive to the
lives of New Hampshire residents and are
highlighted by this committee as
apparently extra-constitutional in
nature comments from the committee
any good bad no opinion representative
weary I I like it
um I I do like the word severe in there
somewhere
um um but I I I do th I think it's
important for for people to understand
that that authorities were
exceeded
okay represent Belcher thank you madam
chair based on the input I have changed
the words significantly to severely such
that it now reads these measures were
documented as being severely disruptive
to the lives of New Hampshire residents
and are highlighted by this committee as
apparently extrac constitutional in
nature
comments okay okay
any other changes to 29 if not let's
move on to page 30
representative
Penza yeah at the bottom of page 29 I
would just love to add a line so it
here's the paragraph it is therefore the
recommendation of this committee that
such excesses of authority the claiming
of police powers to divide the
population order healthy persons Liberty
severely restricted order houses of
worship and private business business
shuttered and the light should never
again be pursued by this government you
I would rather say yeah we
we I would like another sentence that
basically says you know something like
um the multitudes of civil liberties
that were
violated uh throughout the uh you know
the New Hampshire's um response to the
covid-19
um
pandemic the legisl needs to make sure
that that then never happens
again uh representative beler but also I
think in private business it needs to be
plural businesses that's
right so please changed and
fixed and just to uh Echo the sentiment
I I I think the sentiment is accurate
but I think the paragraph before the
last paragraph actually does great
Justice to that sentiment
I agree with representative
beler I I don't think we need to um put
that in
again
exactly any other changes to page
29 it's okay Kelly represent Penza uh
page
e e
any changes to page
30 e
representa Penza just I just want to
make sure that um if if everybody page
it's on we're on 30 we're at the top
paragraph starting off at the
government's recommended vaccines
mandated vaccines rolled out vaccines I
just want to make sure that we are
saying that it's you know this is the
federal and New Hampshire because it was
it was crystal clear that um you know
both of those were happening
simultaneously and I think that this one
piece you know we did a whole laundry
list of
things we also um
conducted propaganda in
censorship we we advertised we did
Billboards in New Hampshire that said
this is your chance you know to get you
know this is your shot to get back on
you know we
basically that's not necessarily
propaganda it was like okay you want to
get back to normal you know go get go
get the shot and um this is your shot to
get back to normal and we did
commercials where it
had the governor uh dror Chan Lori
shonet you know walking in the woods um
telling everybody to get themselves and
their children injected I really believe
that that I want to I want to make that
clear I don't I don't know if that's
considered propaganda we we literally
advertised for this so I I want that in
there representative beler thank you
madam chair and just to address the
members um point I think if you take the
totality of both this section and a
future section that we're coming to into
the full view I I suspect you will be
satisfied with the way those items were
handled
okay thank you for that um any other
changes to page
30 if not let's take a look at
31 representative
Weary at the top of 31 where it starts
out from the gathered testimony of New
Hampshire officials and goes on to talk
about the CDC in the next sentence it it
says it also does not appear they is
does they mean both New Hampshire
officials and
CDC so top of 30
one does it does not it also does not
appear New Hampshire officials or the
[Music]
CDC um there could be anybody it could
even be the public right it does not
appear they were aware of an established
F Narrative of safe and effective I mean
and I think this is one of the questions
we addressed ear on in our intro is we
don't know when they were made aware or
when though you know we can't begin to
understand that represent
poent so after the first sentence you're
talking about that second line that says
it also does not appear they were aware
of an established preferred narrative by
federal authorities of safe and effect
that may even injected bias into Federal
guidance this I mean in New Hampshire
that quote unquote safe and effective
was literally said probably you know a
million times so I
don't I don't agree with that it they
were aware because they said it over and
over and over again okay uh
representative Belcher thank you madam
chair and just to clarify yes indeed
they did but the the purpose of the
sentence here is not to say that they
didn't adopt The Narrative of safe and
effective it's simply to state that they
did not necessarily according to what we
have gathered have access to the federal
data and the private emails that we now
have from the federal government that
highlight that this was not
actually the conclusion of research data
but rather a preferred narrative that
was being promulgated at the federal
level um that was rather uncritically
adopted at the state
level my question then at the end of
that sentence is that may have injected
bias into State guidance would it be it
shouldn't be Federal guidance it should
be State guidance yes I
agree uh represent we could we uh along
the lines of what representative beler
just said perhaps we just say um New
Hampshire officials adopted the
preferred uh narrative by federal of
safe
effective a and carried over that bias
into State
guidance because it's it's their
adoption of the narrative that that that
biased them
toward what they promulgated as state
guidance
oh uh represent Bel uh suggest to take a
shot at this to modify it uh beginning
with it also does not appear that they
were aware of an established preferred
narrative by federal authorities of safe
and effective that may have injected
bias into guidance both state and
federal sounds good to me
any other
comments represent po
off the same sentence in uh in a view
what we just
discussed I don't think it's
like aware is the right word here it
also does not appear a aware of an
established preferred
narrative by federal authorities of safe
and effective what we are trying to say
that they were not aware of full
background why Federal
authorities established this narrative
or
like so the narrative was clear but some
data behind it was hidden from our state
authorities uh so so that's what we need
to
say I I believe that is covered as we
continue through this um section yeah go
go to the next
paragraph e
represent pull is
off I I like the the next paragraph I
still find the first paragraph confusing
but if majority feels it's okay uh I'm
fine with
it okay any other Chang is on
31 okay perfect
representative
Penza okay so this is my plug to get a
sentence in here so
underneath lastly propaganda is defined
by blah blah blah I think what paragraph
uh it's the second it's the second
paragraph cuz thank you there's a Top
Line and then it's really the second
paragraph
um so on
32 I like that we defined what it is I
think we should
state or I think we should list or note
what the state did and how they engaged
in it
spending hundreds of thousands of
dollars on
commercials um car wraps
stuff I mean everything that you could
uh press
releases um press
conferences
Billboards to continue this whole
propaganda like based upon driving fear
as well as
um to go you know to to to go get um the
shot to get back to normal this is your
shot to get back to normal um and I just
I I think all of that is is utterly
disgusting um I think when you get down
further into um it um I think that
representative belum representative
weary did a good job um really bringing
out the
Grievances uh without expressing some of
that and talking about represent Bela
represent where thank you madam chair in
just a second satisfy that um sentiment
I think there can be a simple addition
of the following short paragraph between
uh after that that last one that simply
States the state of New Hampshire
adopted and forwarded narratives during
the pandemic around such items as
stay-at-home vaccination of VAR various
demographics including children the
safety and efficacy of vaccines and
treatments and
more okay represent
weary uh at the risk of being overly
simp
um could may maybe we could just say um
we're engaged in propaganda and
extensive
marketing
that use the public
sphere
of
covid to
um take the vaccine Etc I I something
along those lines because I think
that's much of the extensive marketing
that representative Potenza discussed
was around the VAC obtaining the vaccine
Andor boosters and I think that that I I
think
that's perhaps the the the we should
identify that as kind of the point of
Singularity to kind of you know that
was very concerning in especially in
light of the lack of data as as
discussed in earlier paragraphs I think
if um maybe you have an alternative
there I um I have um something that I'd
like to add to this um and it kind of
brings all of it together but as was
discussed here in a bipartisan
manner that power politics and
money really ruled the
propaganda of the pandemic and I
think by instilling
fear they were able to do that so maybe
instead of listing everything out we
talk about the fear that was instilled
and understand that it was about power
politics and
money and that's why everything was
propagandized I mean that's just a
thought but I'll let the word Smiths
deal with
that if I may take another shot at
trying to put this all together I'm
going to read the whole paragraph to to
put it in context okay lastly propaganda
is defined by the mam Webster dictionary
as ideas facts or allegations spread
deliberately to further one's cause or
to damage an opposing cause as such
anytime an official position or
narrative is adopted by the state an
official speech or media is undertaken
to advance that position or narrative
publicly the state is definitionally
engaged in propaganda this is the case
regardless of the truth or falsity of
the position narrative or propaganda
being engaged in the state of New
Hampshire adopted and forwarded
narratives and engaged in fear-based
marketing during the pandemic around
such items as stay-at-home vaccination
of various demographics including
children I.E our shot to get back to
normal the safety and efficacy of
vaccines and treatments and more these
items were directly related to Federal
funding as well
comments
suggestions
Perfection okay anything else on page 32
because then we are basically done I do
believe you're going to add oh no we're
almost
done okay
3233 any suggestions
page 34
representative
Penza I'm just going to make a comment
because I know we can't change this I
just I wish we would have had well and
maybe we will have more time but um
specifically on monoclonal antibodies
um I can't tell you how how how much um
how many people I talk to concerning
this how many people were um were sick
and that and that needed to get those
and um if you just want to compare New
Hampshire to
Florida Florida made these reibly
accessible to everyone there was not um
there was no problem in supply for those
and it and it worked for a lot of people
that helped them when they were
suffering from covid and our state was
dismal in that um misinformation that
was put on the website where there
someone could get the monocon anybody's
they tried to try to get them and then
they said that they couldn't because it
was only for certain specific people so
I just wanted to make a note that is um
that is something that really helped a
lot of people get better and we um we
failed in that um we failed in that
regard um which is really sad for me
representative belg thank you madam
chair and uh just to highlight that we
did cover this at least briefly in in a
previous uh Committee hearing but I I
was one of those people who was very ill
with covid received an order for
covid-19 monoclonal antibodies but was
nonetheless refused the treatment
apparently because of equity
policy so
I guess my
question in medical terms and I'm not a
doctor but I always thought the first
thing is Do no
harm um
so if someone knows there is a treatment
and you need to get that treatment but
we're picking and choosing who can get
it instead of the person that's there
immediately in there for treating me and
holding it
back what does that say about our system
just asking a
question uh representative
Weary at at the risk of uh going
backwards in our review here I I
would
um I'd like to go back to page 31 from
the uh where it says from the gathered
testimony of New Hampshire officials
I I thought about that second sentence
where it says it does not appear and I
would I do have two sentences which I
wrote out which I think might be be
useful instead of that sentence the two
sentences
are federal authorities created a
narrative of safe and effective that was
unsupported by data and
evidence period State authorities
unaware of the lack of supportive data
adopted the narrative and implemented it
as policy in state
guidance so my question to you is is
lack of knowledge I wouldn't say lack of
knowledge I would say um something
of maybe lack of awareness at the time
or something to that because once
everybody knew then everybody knew right
so just a question
question uh we could say State
authorities at the time on you know
maybe that that would be a good
clarification thank
you
e
e e
if I may I'll just reread this paragraph
down there's been an edit um from the
gathered testimony of New Hampshire
officials it does not appear that these
authorities within our state were aware
of these safety issues at the time that
the CDC had this data Federal
authorities developed a narrative of
safe and effective that was knowingly
not supported by data at the time the
state of New Hampshire authorities
adopted this narrative uncritically and
implemented it as policy and state
guidance it appears that the official
narrative conclusions of federal
authorities and select public private
Partnerships such as some of those
overseeing vaccine SA and efficacy were
readily adopted by relevant New
Hampshire authorities without any
circumspect and critical
review indeed the state epidemiologist
testified that at no point did the state
generate any of her own guidance around
vaccines but rather merely adopted
Federal
guidance any
discussion represent po off yeah I'm
thankful for this change so in terms of
uh Mal clonal antibodies I wonder if we
can include it into two to e or to F
where we talk about executive
legislative and judicial functions on
level of government integration or
cooperation communication and I would
uh increase it to some other treatments
that
were um suppressed by policies of
government so it's not just monoclonal
antibodies it's atin it's G
chloro it's uh uh it's some
um uh treatment protocols that would uh
use uh uh some antivirals earlier than
it was in practice so there were some
treatments that were suppressed so I
wonder if we can uh include it uh in
some of policy uh discussions uh under
number two as a certain paragraph that
there was a adverse effect on medical
practice uh I think that under Equity
measures that may already exist because
we were talking about how things were
applied equitably and how certain people
didn't receive certain things represent
Bel thank you madam chair I I think that
is a whole totally different issue from
the equity policies cuz the it was was a
different thing um it would have to go
somewhere else and while I don't
necessarily disagree with the utility of
it I think at this point it's too late
to go back and add what would
effectively be a whole another section
on suppressed treatments um when we
really probably should have voted on
this 90 seconds
ago um anything else um on any of the
other Pages uh 34 35 and
36 I do have something on 36 and
representative where you go
ahead I might just
suggest I might just suggest uh adding
suppressed treatments the the phrase
suppressed treatments to the top of
34 as as mentioning it as an equity
measure at this point including vaccines
monocon antibodies and suppressed
treatments I like that and and it's it's
there as the record um we've we've
touched upon it under this Equity
concern and then if an opportunity Rises
then we can expand our uh investigation
of that aspect El you know otherwise
okay represent Bela then represent Penza
thank you madam chair if there's a
commune desired to I think we could find
a place to add that I don't think it
belongs under Equity measures the state
and federal government only took two
specific Equity measures that we have in
our record those measures related to
vaccines where certain I believe it was
10% were withheld for administration on
the base of race and uh monoclonal
antibodies from which the federal FDA
administered guidelines that included
significant biases in race there were no
other uh suppression yes there was
suppression but none of that falls under
Equity measures uh represent
Penza so I know we have it's under e
right in on page 34 we're talking about
Equity measures but I will have to say
like suppressed treatments could go in
there if in a little broader spe because
we have a we have a um an emergency
order executive order that literally
stopped a suppressed treatment which was
um um inhalers albuterol as well as um
hydroxy chloroquin and we basically cut
that off for
um everyone in the state so um because
they said that there could be a um a
shortage of that for elderly which was
based upon nothing so I know it doesn't
fall underneath the equity definition
but a suppressed treatment did happen
because of that specifically so that
they were saying that there wasn't
necessarily would be enough for people
that are NE elderly in in in nursing
homes and stuff like that which was
based on nothing which was those
treatments were important especially for
folks that you know um could have had
some early early treatment represent po
off uh I agree and I would suggest
mentioning suppressed treatment either
in G ongoing health impact on New
Hampshire or even better in chapter
number four that we just uh inserted
with recommendation for uh continuation
of the this committee we may mention
that we need to look into suppressed
treatments as well and maybe that's
where it belongs is in the
recommendation section um representative
wary uh there might be an opportunity to
briefly mention supress treatments under
the censorship paragraph under on page
32 because I think that
um
um uh
perhaps
um perhaps in the in this paragraph that
starts further comma censorship is now
known blah blah blah um if if we go down
to the final sentence and perhaps um
insert a brief sentence saying something
censorship also extended to suppressed
treatments period that's perfect I think
that's perfect perfect and I I think I
think you found the perfect spot for it
so any objections
discussion censorship and executive
censorship and executive
action add executive action in there
because it wasn't just censorship they
actually took executive
action put both that put both that in
there in that sentence I think the I
think it conflates it but represent
where
the censorship came through executive
action so um so it would
be
censorship
uh also applies to suppressed
treatments which were censored by
executive action something like that
maybe
please if I may so just to read that
whole actually um I'll just read the
last sentence of that paragraph um which
is right before the last paragraph in
that
section sentence uh adds censorship
efforts included suppression of
treatments and information around
potential treatments for covid-19 that
may have steered policy
yes yes okay excellent uh anything else
uh we're 35 36 36 I have something
on so on 36 the first sentence reads we
receive substantial testimony and
evidence on the topic of long covid a
variable condition thought to be brought
on by various toxic components of
covid-19
infection I do believe in testimony and
I could be wrong
that the ratio of those with just covid
and those of those vaccinated who reive
covid uh those with the that were
vaccinated um the percentage is much
higher of them developing covid I think
it was 85% to
15% so um I think on the evidence of the
so I don't know if just saying that
covid
please thank you madam chair I think
what you're referring to might be the
rate of developing particularly
myocarditis but I don't have the exact
number on top of my head as far
as um where that came in although
perhaps we could add something more
General
that certain um certain uh issues were
more uh prevalent among the vaccinated
group or or maybe we just had received
substantial te testimony and evidence on
the topic of long covid a variable
condition thought to be brought on by
various toxic components of covid-19
including those that were vaccinated
correct um and maybe that's where what
you put in
because it's it's long thought that if
you were vaccinated you were kind of
immune from everything but that was the
original thought represent
poens yeah this is a really good catch
um there's two types of long Co right
now that has been documented for well
over um well over a year you know we're
probably on you know um upwards of a
year and a half now um from doctors and
and experts all over the country so that
long Co is two things right some people
that got very very sick from covid and
having those after effects as well as
long Co is is through um folks that were
in sense vaccine injured um some of them
had covid and some of them didn't and so
I I really believe that including all of
that in that um in that first line is
important uh and the reason I brought
that up is because Dr vau when he was
here I asked him the percentage of his
patients that he was treating with long
covid were vaccinated and those that
were not and he said 15% of the long Co
his long covid patients were were not
vaccinated and 85% of them were um and
that's where I came up with that
information uh represent B thank you
madam chair I I think I just understood
what what exactly you you were talking
about the trouble is for us to make a
statement that is um fairly Final on
that based on that number alone is is
something that because correlation is
not necess equal causation we don't know
the relative numbers of people who are
vaxed in the pop ation versus those in
his clinic so we wouldn't actually be
able to draw final conclusions as to
rates or
percentages
um and and it may well be the case that
that the numbers are are you know linked
to the numbers who are just generally
vaccinating the population in which case
those numbers might actually not
represent anything
meaningful you know I will have to agree
with you um and um another question is
is seen as this was the last section we
were going to add another section I
believe uh we talked about it at the
beginning um do you have that also
unless there's any more discussion on
this represent
Penza yeah I would make two changes to
that first paragraph on 36 where it says
this committee has received I would take
out substantial and just put testimony
and then and then I keep the same thing
because in the second sentence you say
we have likewise received I take out
that that's substantial testimony and
evidence regarding vaccine chloridine
injury um and illness uh which you could
put in parentheses you know which is
also being called long covid okay so I
think that's kind of important too you
don't have to do that if not and then
also thought to be related to the toxic
Sprite protein of SARS Koby 2 as well as
possible harmful effects of MRA and
Technology um so I I think you should
take out substantial in both of those
lines I would
con represent where and and maybe just
um to representative Pena's point is
maybe under or after illness may be put
parenthetically including long covid
correct represent PO is
off yeah if it's just onqu it might be
fine I just wonder if we need to clarify
that
uh it's more like misdiagnosed as long
Co so it's not necessarily definition of
long Co but it's more like uh it's
similar so sometimes it is misdiagnosed
as long
Co so maybe in paresis we can uh say
that um
sometimes misdiagnosed as long
co uh represent we maybe maybe just
something like um illness uh open parent
including what is often diagnosed as
long covid yeah that' be great close
parin I I don't necessarily disagree
with it but unless we have that evidence
in our record it's a speculative
statement and I don't know that I like
it okay
no we do
not okay um represent
weary did did uh representative lucus
talk about that at
all she did she may have I don't
remember okay that was many ago
yeah it's been a lot of information um
so once this is done I think we talked
about adding another section after this
at the beginning of the hearing if you
could just go over that representative
Belcher thank you madam chair um so I I
believe the section is the conclusion um
section four um or alternatively we can
insert the minority statement here and
make that section four make the
conclusion section five either way f
with me but anyway conclusion this
committee has spent considerable time
reviewing the events of the past several
years with regards to the state's uh
response to the pandemic receiving
testimony and documents and making
recommendations for future for the
future to the benefit of the state
however very much remains to be reviewed
assessed and many more recommendations
are likely to result as a consequence of
further inquiry because of this this
committee recommends and concludes that
our work is not yet concluded with the
issues with the issues in this report
and recommends that consideration be
given that this committee be reinstated
in the new house session of 2025 2026 to
continue toward these ends and to the
benefit of the citizens in New Hampshire
further it is recommended that the
mission parameters of this committee be
slightly amended to open up the scope of
inquiry such that a more complete
picture be available to the members of
the public to the members and to the
public I have one go ahead and represent
poent yeah I have one change so where
you
where it says because of this the
committee recommends and concludes that
our work is not yet concluded let's use
it so without saying conclude and
conclude let's just um because of this
the committee recommend recommends and
has decided or whatever or come to a
consensus or whatever it may be that our
work is not yet concluded so just so
we're not saying that or or maybe we we
we maybe we say that
ongoing uh
information still needs something to
that needs to be uh gathered and
represented where we go ahead and word
Smith that please just the uh on ongoing
investigation of this needs to
continue right in a science-based fact
finding
manner okay and I would like to thank
represent Telles for being so patient
with us
um because she has some changes uh and
then I'll get to you representative p is
off um but representative tell has some
changes she'd like to make to her
Minority Report
also thank you I already I already made
them to the electronic version I'm going
to just show this to you I'll review
what it what they were but let me hand
this to you and then I can email the PDF
so I'll review a few typographical
things if you want to look at your um
print out from earlier so in the first
sentence I added an S to the Democratic
members um
the the
um where is
it I deleted a a comma in the last
sentence uh right before was
difficult and then in the paragraph we
discussed a lot where it mentions the co
after action report I just substituted a
a everywhere in that
paragraph and um where it says please
see attachment B I just made the
sentence for the AAR removing the
parenthetical and then finally in the
last sentence the a was not
alone um I removed in New Hampshire part
because it got it was kind of confusing
so the AAR was not alone in concluding
that New Hampshire's Co response was
sound is sort of how the sentence ended
up and so if that seems okay because
it's just sort of grammatical things I
will email I I think they are PF yeah I
I think they're fine in rep and PS off
you had something else you want to
say no um if there's any other further
recommendations or changes uh if not I
would like to have a vote on the report
um well so I I have a procedural
question yes yeah my understanding is
that we vote on your report and then I
request submission of The Minority
Report correct okay okay I'd like to
take a vote on the majority report um
representative Belcher yeah U Madam
chair just to make sure this is all
correct uh I would make a motion to vote
on the final committee report do I have
a
second okay represent poll is
off second
okay represent Penza call the role can
just do us in
order representative poos off
yes representative weary yes
representative Belcher yes
representative Penza yes represent oops
sorry oh my gosh
I haven't done this right representative
tell us uh
no yeah and representative Kwa
yes so the majority report um has been
adopted we will now vote on The Minority
Report as edited uh by representative
Telles uh and this was an adoption of
the edited report by the majority also
that we just voted on uh representative
um Penza I would like to I'll make the
motion to adopt The Minority Report um
and I'd ask for a
second I'll second
it please call the
role representative po off yes
representative weary yes Representative
beler
no representative resentative tellas yes
oh representative Penza yes
representative ktoa
yes well I would like to thank everyone
for being patient this morning and going
through everything and uh for all the
work that everyone has input onto this
in this committee I appreciate that and
um I hope everyone has a good afternoon
enjoy
thank you did everybody oh